blue skies above gatwick for those
escaping the heat this weekend but
they'll be quieter than planned from
next month after britain's second
busiest airport cut thousands of flights
to avoid chaos during its summer peak
gatwick normally operates 900 flights a
day in july and august but will now
limit daily flights to 825 each day in
july rising to 850 daily in august in
total that will cut nearly 4 000 flights
around seven percent of the total
gatwick say passengers will be moved to
similar flights and easyjet predicts it
will be able to re-accommodate anyone
affected but it still leaves abby and
thousands like her wondering if their
holiday is one of those that will be
affected i have to fly into lisbon
airport and then i have to catch a bus
on a predetermined day that i've booked
a ticket for for a five hour trip to the
festival site so it's if i miss this bus
there's there's no just oh well i'll
just i'll just get the next one oh well
i'll just grab a cab it's going to be
very difficult to actually make my way
to the festival
flights have been cut to avoid a repeat
of huge delays over the jubilee weekend
when staff shortages at airports around
the country saw airlines cancel a
thousand flights at short notice
heathrow avoided the worst of the
disruption and are confident they'll do
so again after british airways cut 10 of
its schedule but the boss told me it
will take time to return to normal
i think it'll take 12 to 18 months for
the whole industry to get all of its
capacity back to where it was before the
pandemic and that's not just
across the uk it has to be across europe
as well because we are affected by
staffing issues at other airports around
the world very skilled jobs have been
lost and now we're having to as an
industry recruit people back train them
up again to be able to serve passengers
and that just takes time
even here there are 12 000 vacancies
across airlines security and support
services
the airline industry shed tens of
thousands of workers during the pandemic
once the skies reopened restrictions
lifted they have simply been unable to
staff up adequately to meet our demand
long denied to get away and start
traveling again
manchester birmingham cardiff and
edinburgh airports have all said they
have no plans to cut flights that
promise and passenger patience will be
tested shortly paul kelso sky news at
heathrow